a freestyle rapper I make up raps on the
spot you tell me what you want to rap
out I do a rap about that what would you
like a rap about
the Phillies
are they that's the team in the World
Series right cool [__] I'm literally
if it wasn't on the TV upstairs I would
have had no idea you're like rap about
cream cheese Chris that's all we want
the Phillies
people over
here what would you like a rap about
did you say do you say dog abortions so
I was like don't don't suggest dogs who
like but I've got to work around on that
Chris
foreign
dog abortions thank you very much I mean
it's weird that I'm more enthusiastic
about that than the Phillies but that's
I can understand what that would be like
I don't know a single what's the name of
a player on the Phillies
Bryce Harper the most white name ever
right I don't even need to look at him
you he could be a quarterback with that
name right
Bryce Harper and the Phillies what
what's his position throw it your hitty
or catchy
pity
dog abortions and the Phillies middle of
the room are hand up so polite this is
this is what happens when a British
person raps yeah yeah what do you want
to rap about
Liz trusses Saturday 9pm underwear well
done number one for knowing the name of
the shortest lived prime minister ever
um she was beaten by a lettuce
um
she was wearing different under why were
you checking this out this is horrendous
all right
she changed into her Saturday night
underwear okay cool cool let's trust is
Saturday night 9 pm underwear uh back
corner of the room what do you want to
rap about
new you [__] unimaginative prick no
come on someone else do better
the first Thanksgiving turkey thank you
that's pretty good and then this final
section you got the last one What's it
gonna be
great look at this yeah yeah
first Thanksgiving turkey Bryce Harper
in the Phillies dog abortions Liz
trusses Saturday night underwear and uh
[__] I'm gonna drop on the floor
right um okay this is going to be a
freestyle rap and uh let's let's have
some fun with it can we get that beat
pumped a little bit
yeah that's what I'm talking about cool
I'm gonna enjoy myself so let's uh drop
this in dropping on the beat off we go
we call him Wally I'm sorry you'd be
saying wild or with the red and white
stripes party every night but he hits 45
like what's my [__] life about I just
spend every day of my life in big crowds
and I'm trying to hide I've got a wizard
friend and the dog with the bone the
yellow black striped guy won't leave me
alone I'm in the children's books they
can learn to discern pick me out when
they're in school at half term they go
on with the days they don't bother about
me where's walls oh [__] I'm just gonna
leave my lady is the name Wendy begins
with the w no need to offend me let me
gather thee she a fine lady but I feel
silly who the [__] are these guys
playing for the Phillies Bryce Harper
he's a nice starter he can get the ball
hard he can hit it farther out the park
everyone's like oh that's fun where's it
gone far across the car park home run
will they score some I don't even care I
know the other team team like the stars
in the air like the Houston Astros
didn't they cheat sometime they were
stealing all of the signs and their
logos orange I know more about them than
the Phillies maybe they'll knock them
out then it's a route I hope that it
goes to game seven I really don't I find
the sport rather unpleasant I'll be safe
I break it down like a portion tear it
apart like a poor dog abortion I'm
reaching in yeah just stand there regret
the Great Dane with the coat hanger she
says I was impregnated by the owl
station wish I'd waited for someone of
my own breed feeling like the boss I
don't want any more dogs to get crossed
it's useful I see the Spaniel and the
poodle they walk in Walking slightly
unusual the ones like I'm four months
along cause the gestation of the dog it
ain't long but she be struggling gotta
check this she can't get the abortion
why this dog's in Texas they're so upset
they can't stand this you better take
your [__] dog to Kansas they had a
referee Ender voting on The Choice she
can get it out my body my choice that's
the dog that is what they say [__]
hell this crowd in New York today that's
for you they're like we're Democrats
liberal I can struggle with this I'm
like yes you're the first bird please
don't hurt me gobble gobble I'm a plump
Thanksgiving turkey why would it happen
they're on the coast the settlers will
come in saying your toast we're giving
you the blankets lots and lots you're
gonna perish getting all the smallpox
but actually we've got the turkey plump
and fat why is it Thanksgiving bird who
the thunker that it's very dry you
should get some chicken or a goose
that's what we do at Christmas time in
Britain we should have a truce change
some recipes trade in all the food one
last thing yeah I'm in the mood remind
me what was the other thing we did you
can Shout
of course she gets it out she'd be in
the morning just put saw some plain
white why front saying no I need to
change I'm the Prime Minister for 44
days the naughtiest lady yes she [__]
slaves walking out on number 10 in the
black lace thong saying even though I
run economy wrong it's 9pm on Saturday
so I sash it out the door there we go
that's a wrap so there's no [__] more